anaëlle et samuel font partie des
nombreux jeunes à la recherche d'un
emploi leur permettant de mettre qu'un
pas dans le monde professionnel
depuis le vent la mission locale nord
s'est engagé dans le but d'initier
différentes actions et agir
une initiative porteuse aujourd'hui
qu'une trentaine d'entreprises tous
secteurs étaient présentes au les sports
du moment nous réagissons à la demande
des entreprises sur des postes bien
précis et notre coeur de batailles c'est
de trouver la bonne pointure pour les
postes demandés mt 10 platinum est
toujours au chalenge de poids puisque
nous sommes souvent demandés nous avons
des demandes parfois extrêmement
délicate pour les chefs d'entreprise
pour les entreprises de la place mais
notre bataille permanente socialiste
recrutement c'est justement de pouvoir
répondre à ses demandes au niveau local
de préférence des professionnels
attentifs à toutes les demandes des
jeunes au bout tout type de contrat de
travail comme des cdd cdi intérim
une manne pour les jeunes du nord
caraïbes et atlantique qui seront mieux
armés sur le marché de l'emploi
j'ai passé un entretien sa poule et ça
s'est bien passé donc je vais voir ce
qu'il ya ailleurs est trouvé
ce qui m'attire mercer en la personne de
ico mobile propose un stage c'est ce que
je suis venu chercher aujourd'hui très
intéressant dans le domaine que je
recherchais neuvième édition que de
satisfaction la mission locale nord
atlantique peut une fois de plus se
targuer d'avoir réussi à réunir en un
seul et même lieu jeunesse et
entreprises
nous avons une des entreprises qui ont
entendu et qui sont venus spontanément
nous dire qu'ils sont prêts à jouer le
jeu et qu'ils ont des recrutements moi
je trouve ça vraiment très bien que
l'entreprise martiniquaise juste ce jeu
là et s'implique complètement données de
l'association des jeunes
et puis voir des jeunes intéressés voire
des parents accompagner leurs enfants et
leur dire allez il ya des offres
d'emploi là va prendre va prendre des
informations vata soir devant
l'employeur
moi je trouve ça vraiment génial je
crois qu'aujourd'hui on a réussi une
belle opération avec nos jeunes et nos
chaînes entreprises plus d'une centaine
d'offres les employeurs par de
satisfaire des jeunes seront revus sous
peu pour une éventuelle embauche